[Musique]
op à paris saclay travaille sur deux
aspects des sols c'est à dire dans tout
les sens tous les sols qui sont excavés
aucun n'est sorti de la zac est
réutilisé pour l'ensemble des espaces
publics donc une partie est stockée sur
le territoire des actes directement look
en deux parties la partie seul plutôt
fertile donc les premiers mètres et la
partie sol stérile donc les mails et
mettre plus profond tout ce qui est laid
soit le plus profond on réutilise
directement les terres fertiles pour
faire des aménagements paysagers
essentiellement et tout ce qui est
terrible pour faire des structures de
chaussée ou destructeur de trottoirs à
une deuxième approche qu'on a adopté
dernièrement c'est essayer justement de
faire que ses seules stérile deviennent
fertile en gros pouvoir créer des soldes
fertile appartient des sols plus profond
des limites profond donc c'est ce qu'on
réalise sur la plateforme qui est
derrière moi l'enrichissement de limos
conteste sur cette plateforme c'est la
capacité des limons stérile avec de la
matière organique en fait du compost ou
tout simplement mélangé la capacité car
à cette terre ah c'est à devenir fertile
et donc à engendrer la croissance des
arbres que vous voyez derrière moi comme
cette plateforme elle permet de comparer
une croissance dans un sol stériles un
aliment stérile avec nos limon laquelle
on a ajouté du compost
le but final de cette expérimentation
c'est à partir de tous les lits mots
qu'on a qu'on a extrait qu'on a en
grande quantité et qu'on aura sûrement
quantité surnuméraires par rapport à
tous les espaces publics on a créé ce
sera de créer des terres fertiles qu'on
pourra réutiliser pour autre chose que
ce soient les aménagements paysagers de
la zac ou éventuellement les
aménagements paysagers ou les espaces
verts qui peut y avoir à l'extérieur de
la zac qui sera vraiment dans un second
temps vraiment le premier temps c'est
d'avoir suffisamment de terre végétale
de terres fertiles pour pouvoir aménager
notre nozach l'expérimentation va se
dérouler entre 18 mois et deux ans avec
des premiers résultats au bout d'un an
donc sachant que cela commence il a
dernièrement on peut compter vraiment un
an à partir de maintenant donc début
d'été 2018 on aura des premiers
résultats et ensuite pour la gestion des
terres de manière générale ça va venir
au fur et à mesure du développement des
actes donc clairement ce serait quelque
chose s'il sera en rien au développement
des axes si le planning des ac dépasse
2020 2021 2022
à quelque part la gestion des terres
suivra aussi ce planning se plaignent
[Musique]